Katrina: 我靠我隐形眼镜掉了
Katrina: Oh no, I lost my contact lens.
Shure: 没了找不见了是吗
Shure: It's gone? You can't find it?
Katrina: 我以为放那个我那隐形眼镜盒里摸
Katrina: I thought I put it in my contact lens case but...
Katrina: 只摸到一格
Katrina: I only felt one side.
Katrina: 我要点一个外卖
Katrina: I need to order some food.
Katrina: 我现在就是一直能看得见一直看不见
Katrina: Right now, I can see clearly and then can't see at all.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈太抽象
Katrina: Hahaha, it's so abstract!
Katrina: 找谁啊点
Katrina: Who should I order from?
Tasha: 我没转头
Tasha: I didn't turn my head.
Shure: 要不我那有450你先对付用着
Shure: I have 450 (units), want to use mine for now?
Katrina: 没事我现在点一个找
Katrina: It's fine, I'll order something now.
Katrina: 找谁点他
Katrina: Who should I order from?
Shure: 找他点对
Shure: Order from him, right.
Katrina: 吃什么
Katrina: What should we eat?
其他人:你会做吗
Others: Can you cook?
Katrina: 嗯不是
Katrina: Hmm, no.
Shure: 不是点点点点点外卖
Shure: No, no, no, order takeout.
其他人:那个在在啊
Others: Is that one there?
Shure: 啊那呢那呢
Shure: Ah, where?
其他人:那那那是在薛明主那还是在孟威尔那
Others: Is it with Xue Mingzhu or Meng Weier?
Shure: 那呢
Shure: Where?
Jake:对他也在点了
Jake: Yes, he's ordering too.
Katrina: 就像站在烈日骄阳的看看看看
Katrina: It's like standing under the scorching sun, seeing, seeing, seeing...
Shure: 他说有一些是虚拟号
Shure: He said some numbers are virtual.
其他人：要不你先点什么
Others: How about you order something first?
Katrina: 麦当劳OK哈哈哈
Katrina: McDonald's, okay, hahaha.
其他人:对
Others: Right.
Lucia:啊这样的吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia:但是我给他发了截图
Lucia: But I sent him a screenshot.
Lucia:就是那个取件码
Lucia: It's the pickup code.
Katrina: 又想吃冰淇淋
Katrina: I also want ice cream.
Jake:问题不大
Jake: Not a big problem.
Shure: （歌词）这一幅扇面画的水晶宫啊啊
Shure: (Lyrics) This fan painting of the Crystal Palace, ah ah...
其他人：我靠
Others: Oh my god.
其他人：这不这晚上在这debug非常的舒适
Others: Debugging here at night is super comfortable.
Shure: 有没有可能不debug
Shure: Is it possible to not debug?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 啊就我们在这吃吃喝喝不更舒适吗
Shure: Wouldn't it be more comfortable just eating and drinking here?
Shure: 怎么能把自己PUA成这个样子了
Shure: How did we end up PUA-ing ourselves like this?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：坏了坏了
Others: Oh no, oh no
其他人：我要反思了嗯
Others: I need to reflect on this, hmm
Shure: 哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my god
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Shure: 他他说
Shure: He said
Shure: 晚上在这debug岂不是非常的舒适
Shure: Bringing up bugs here at night is so comfortable
Shure: 我说有没有可能你在这坐着更舒适呢
Shure: I said, is it possible that sitting here is even more comfortable?
Jake:哈哈哈反思
Jake: Hahaha reflect
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人:我要反思
Others: I need to reflect
其他人:我是爱反思的中国人
Others: I'm a Chinese who loves to reflect 社会问题
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Shure: 喂你好
Shure: Hello
Jake:群里问问吧
Jake: Ask in the group
Shure: 哎好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 我马上来取一下
Shure: I'll go get it right away
Jake:发了哈
Jake: Sent it
其他人:好嘞安慕希菠萝酸奶麦旋风
Others: Alright, Anmuxi pineapple yogurt McFlurry
其他人:我靠这个看着就想吃
Others: Wow, it looks so appetizing
Jake:买一赠一了
Jake: Buy one, get one free
Jake:甜点不能太多
Jake: Can't have too many desserts
Katrina: （歌词）就像站在烈日骄阳大桥上
Katrina: (Lyrics) Like standing on a scorching sunny bridge
Jake:就这个看着给外国人震慑一下
Jake: Just looking at this would intimidate foreigners
Katrina: （歌词）眼泪狂奔滴落在我的脸
Katrina: (Lyrics) Tears streaming down my face
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm hmm
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 这是几号线来着
Katrina: Which subway line is this?
Katrina: 我也想去看看
Katrina: I want to go take a look too
Katrina: 啊啊
Katrina: Ah ah
Katrina: 怎么是北大的
Katrina: Why is it Peking University?
Katrina: 只有北大才能上霍格沃兹吗
Katrina: Can only Peking University students go to Hogwarts?
Katrina: 拿到就好
Katrina: As long as you got it
Katrina: 就是那个蓝莓
Katrina: It's that blueberry one
Katrina: 拿到就好
Katrina: As long as you got it
Katrina: 因为当时他可以满多少免那个配送费
Katrina: Because back then, you could get free delivery if you reached a certain amount
Katrina: 你知道吧
Katrina: You know, right?
Katrina: 然后我就非要凑那个金额
Katrina: And then I just had to make up that amount.
Katrina: 然后你那个蓝莓你吃了
Katrina: And then you ate those blueberries.
Katrina: 就对你眼睛好一点
Katrina: They should be good for your eyes.
Katrina: 我跟你说现在真的巨搞笑
Katrina: I'm telling you, it's really funny now.
Katrina: 我发现我我有一只隐形眼镜
Katrina: I realized I have one contact lens.
Katrina: 它不在那个眼镜盒里
Katrina: It's not in the contact lens case.
Katrina: 我现在就是一个独行侠的状态
Katrina: So now I'm like a one-eyed bandit.
Katrina: 然后我要点个外卖送一下
Katrina: Now I need to order some takeout delivery.
Katrina: （歌词）就像站在烈日骄阳的桥上
Katrina: (lyrics) Just like standing on a bridge under the blazing sun.
Katrina: 好香啊
Katrina: Smells so good.
其他人：是这个味吗
Others: Is this the right smell?
其他人：不是味
Others: No, it's not.
其他人：那个鸡蛋一打打
Others: Those eggs, when beaten, give off this smell?
Katrina: 不是是那个
Katrina: No, it's that.
其他人：打开了就这么香吗
Others: Is it so fragrant when opened?
Tasha: 这不是鸡蛋的问题吧
Tasha: It's not the eggs, right?
Jake:找到了这算没有
Jake: Found it, does this count?
其他人:那是哪个香
Others: Which one is it?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Katrina: 龙舌兰要点外卖
Katrina: Tequila needs to be ordered as takeout.
其他人：确实要搬出来我在外面debug
Others: Indeed, need to move out, I'm debugging outside.
其他人：在外面debug特别的凉快
Others: Debugging outside is really cool.
Shure: （歌词）这一幅山面子孝孙贤
Shure: (lyrics) This scene of filial sons and virtuous grandsons.
Katrina: 6.6公里我操
Katrina: 6.6 kilometers, damn.
Katrina: 附近都没有卖眼镜的
Katrina: No stores nearby selling glasses.
Shure: 我们是不是应该一会排练一下
Shure: Should we rehearse a bit later?
Shure: 明天的歌曲
Shure: For tomorrow's song.
Katrina: 哦忘了哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh, I forgot, hahaha.
Shure: 工人怎么变P人了这两天
Shure: How did workers turn into a batch of people these days?
Katrina: 再待两天
Katrina: Stay for two more days.
Katrina: 我完蛋了
Katrina: I'm doomed.
Jake:哈哈一个批房啊
Jake: Haha, it's like a batch room.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:啊这是一个批房啊
Jake: Ah, this is a batch room.
Jake:进来的人一定是P人
Jake: Everyone who comes in is a batch person.
Katrina: 嗯我要完蛋了
Katrina: Hmm, I'm doomed.
Jake:点完了都点完了
Jake: Ordered, all ordered.
Jake:都点了我还没点
Jake: Ordered, I haven't ordered yet.
Lucia:我还没点
Lucia: I haven't ordered yet.
Jake:哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你选哪一個
Jake: Which one do you choose?
Jake:加一看你选哪一个加1
Jake: Add one, let's see which one you choose.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun dun
其他人：这个可以了
Others: This one is fine.
Jake:所以还是没找着是吧
Jake: So, you still haven't found it, right?
Tasha: 没找着没关系
Tasha: It's okay if we haven't found it.
Jake:不行
Jake: No, it's not okay.
Jake:哼这包还在这
Jake: Hmph, this bag is still here.
Jake:包还没变过呢
Jake: The bag hasn't changed.
Jake:开始魔法
Jake: Let's start the magic.
Tasha: 知道那里出了问题
Tasha: I know where the problem is.
Jake:你猜是谁
Jake: Guess who it is.
Tasha: 好了洗洗我们下一个吧
Tasha: Alright, let's wash it and move on to the next one.
Jake:不是
Jake: No.
Jake:no哈哈哈
Jake: No, hahaha.
其他人:咱们往里面加点那个
Others: Let's add some of that.
Tasha: 那也得出来再加了
Tasha: We should add it after we take it out.
其他人：我现在正好拿那个 mm
Others: I'm just grabbing that mm.
Tasha: 可以啊你想买
Tasha: Okay, if you want to buy it.
Tasha: 买
Tasha: Buy it.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
其他人：真的
Others: Really.
Tasha: 不用戴手套的
Tasha: You don't need to wear gloves.
Tasha: 你这么爱吃菠萝吗
Tasha: Do you love eating pineapple this much?
其他人:就是随便加点
Others: Just add some casually.
其他人:加点菠萝然后草莓
Others: Add some pineapple and strawberries.
Jake:主要是看到的菠萝
Jake: Mainly because you saw the pineapple.
Jake:他说看到草莓应该也会加
Jake: He said if he saw strawberries, he would add those too.
Tasha: 会好吃吗
Tasha: Will it taste good?
Jake:你不得切一切
Jake: You should cut it up.
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 好嘞
Tasha: Got it.
其他人:但是我不知道他家烤菜是不是我一样
Others: But I don't know if his grilled dishes are like mine.
其他人:用的烤菠萝
Others: Using grilled pineapple.
其他人:是是是
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人：烤菠萝不都是待在烤架上多烤
Others: Grilled pineapple is usually grilled on the rack longer.
Jake:火烤啊
Jake: Fire grill it.
Katrina: 你知道烤菠萝吗
Katrina: Do you know about grilled pineapple?
Jake:上火
Jake: It's getting hot.
Tasha: 这在哪开啊
Tasha: Where do you open this?
Tasha: 拿12个
Tasha: Take 12 of them.
Jake:哦这边有镊子
Jake: Oh, there are tweezers here.
Tasha: 把托找一下行吗
Tasha: Can you find the tray?
Jake:把什么托
Jake: Which tray?
Tasha: 托
Tasha: The tray.
Jake:对我在找托
Jake: Yeah, I'm looking for the tray.
其他人:那我就不客气了
Others: Then I won't be polite.
其他人：你需要做个啥
Others: What do you need to make?
其他人：蛋挞
Others: Egg tarts.
Tasha: 这个蛋挞很简单
Tasha: These egg tarts are very simple.
Tasha: 来个简单的
Tasha: Let's make something simple.
Shure: 哦好的好的
Shure: Oh, okay, okay.
Tasha: 这个我做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made this many times.
Tasha: 提拉米苏也做过好多遍
Tasha: I've made tiramisu many times too.
Tasha: 这两个不会失败的
Tasha: These two never fail.
Tasha: 还买了一个专业的
Tasha: I even bought a professional one.
Jake:这蓝莓怎么这么丑啊
Jake: Why do these blueberries look so ugly?
其他人：哦这样的
Others: Oh, like this.
其他人：哈哈哈什么呵呵
Others: Hahaha, what do you mean "hehe"?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 呵我们
Tasha: Heh, we...
Jake:教师傅撕保鲜袋
Jake: Master teacher tearing cling film.
Tasha: 我我我好像学会了
Tasha: I think I've learned it.
Tasha: 看你这样操作
Tasha: Watching you do it like this.
Jake:真的没有吗
Jake: Really, there's no more?
Lucia:我好了
Lucia: I'm done.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Tasha: 你还记得吗
Tasha: Do you still remember?
Tasha: 那天我们明明一起把那个托
Tasha: That day we clearly put the tray...
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 盘削在这的结果就不见了
Tasha: ...right here and then it just disappeared.
其他人：真的打不开
Others: Really can't open it.
Jake:这不合理啊
Jake: This doesn't make sense.
Jake:我来打
Jake: Let me do it.
Jake:你拿这个打
Jake: You use this to beat.
Jake:我不要这个
Jake: I don't want this.
其他人:打打不开一点
Others: Can you beat it a bit?
Jake:真的
Jake: Really.
Katrina: 真的哎
Katrina: Really, hey.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia:有人要去取快递吗
Lucia: Is anyone going to pick up the delivery?
Jake:啊他可以现在单独去取吗
Jake: Oh, can he go pick it up by himself now?
Lucia:他说他现在忙不过来
Lucia: He said he's too busy right now.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Lucia:您能帮忙取一下吗
Lucia: Can you help pick it up?
Jake:他说让自己取是吧
Jake: He said to get it himself, right?
Tasha: 你干嘛带上
Tasha: Why are you bringing that?
Jake:因为比较平
Jake: Because it's flat.
Jake:对是吧多好解冻
Jake: Yeah, right, it's easier to thaw.
Tasha: 别倒
Tasha: Don't spill it.
Jake:哎呀好冰啊
Jake: Oh, it's so cold.
Tasha: 一二三四五六七八九十
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Tasha: 1112 好
Tasha: Eleven, twelve. Okay.
Tasha: 把它拆开就行
Tasha: Just tear it open.
Jake:哎呀好冰好冰
Jake: Oh, it's so cold, so cold.
Jake:不行了不行了不行了不行了不行了
Jake: I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't, I can't.
Jake:冻坏了冻坏了
Jake: It's freezing.
Jake:哎哟我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
其他人:好冰
Others: So cold.
Jake:就是蛋挞皮放我手上
Jake: It's just the egg tart crusts on my hand.
其他人：那你那个手不戴着手套吗
Others: Aren't you wearing gloves?
Jake:蛋挞放在了外边
Jake: The egg tarts are outside.
Jake:找到了
Jake: Found them.
Lucia:而且他说他申通那个取了
Lucia: And he said he already picked up the Shentong package.
Tasha: 点什么还在点吗
Tasha: Are you still ordering?
Lucia:但是就没有啊
Lucia: But it's not there.
Jake:不不不点了不点了
Jake: No, no, no, not ordering anymore.
Tasha: 500多块钱怎么吃到500多的
Tasha: How did we spend over 500 yuan?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:不知道
Jake: No idea.
其他人：才几个人啊
Others: How many people are there?
Tasha: 我靠这个人谁
Tasha: Oh my, who is this?
Tasha: 太过分了
Tasha: This is too much.
Tasha: 吃一个77块钱的套餐
Tasha: Someone ordered a 77-yuan set meal.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:谁呀
Jake: Who was it?
Tasha: 我只吃了那个22块钱的套餐
Tasha: I only ordered a 22-yuan set meal.
Jake:揪出来
Jake: Let's find out who it is.
其他人：揪出来
Others: Let's find out who it is.
Tasha: 揪出来我只吃了27块钱
Tasha: I only spent 27 yuan.
Tasha: 他吃七十几
Tasha: He spent more than seventy.
Jake:没关系分掉
Jake: It's okay, we'll split it.
Jake:瓜分掉
Jake: We'll divide it up.
Jake:到时候大家盲选好吧
Jake: Everyone will choose blindly then.
Jake:我就在这拖着嘛
Jake: I'll just drag it along here.
Tasha: 你把这个麦津会员开了是吗
Tasha: Did you open this membership?
Jake:我我我没动他
Jake: I didn't touch it.
Tasha: 因为他写他只要19块钱
Tasha: Because it says it only costs 19 yuan.
Tasha: 但他这一单可以减37块5
Tasha: But this order can save 37.5 yuan.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 我靠怎么会买到56068块钱
Tasha: How did we end up spending 56,068 yuan?
其他人：咱们桌咱这么多人呢
Others: There are so many of us at this table.
Jake:咱总共9个
Jake: There are nine of us in total.
Alice:是不是有的套餐那个啥
Alice: Maybe some of the sets...
Jake:咱总共10个人
Jake: There are ten of us in total.
Alice:超过一份就原价了还是怎么样
Alice: If you get more than one set, does it go back to the original price?
其他人：9个
Others: Nine.
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: This is ridiculous.
Jake:9个人吗
Jake: Nine people?
Tasha: 我们是选这个餐厅吗
Tasha: Did we choose this restaurant?
Tasha: 哦好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:因为撤嗯
Jake: Because we canceled, um.
Tasha: 是选这个餐厅
Tasha: We chose this restaurant.
Jake:67899个哦
Jake: 67,899, oh.
Tasha: 我靠太离谱了
Tasha: This is too much.
其他人：你们车坐四个
Others: Four of you in your car.
其他人：我们车坐四个
Others: Four of us in our car.
Jake:这么回事哦
Jake: Oh, that's how it is.
其他人：呃四个
Others: Uh, four.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You did it.
Jake:哦行吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:你们做的
Jake: You did it.
Tasha: 568块钱啊
Tasha: 568 yuan?
Jake:好 9个9个
Jake: Alright, nine, nine.
Jake:点了500多
Jake: We ordered over 500.
Alice:哒哒哒
Alice: Da da da.
Jake:也行吧合理合理
Jake: It's reasonable, I guess.
其他人：660
Others: 660.
Katrina: 那个酒要现在点吗
Katrina: Should we order the wine now?
Katrina: 风舌兰没买到
Katrina: Couldn't get the Windtongue Orchid.
Jake:嗯买到了哎
Jake: Hmm, got it.
Jake:不是你点到了
Jake: No, you clicked it.
Jake:已经买完了
Jake: It's already bought out.
Katrina: 啊那
Katrina: Ah, well.
Jake:外卖卖完了
Jake: The delivery is sold out.
Katrina: 爽
Katrina: Nice.
其他人:这烤箱还好垃圾
Others: This oven is still trash.
Tasha: 这烤箱还垃圾
Tasha: This oven is still trash.
Alice:坏了
Alice: It's broken.
Jake:这还特地租的呢
Jake: We even rented this.
其他人:相当垃圾
Others: It's quite trash.
Katrina: 嘿嘿怎么垃圾了
Katrina: Heh heh, how is it trash?
Tasha: 怎么垃圾了
Tasha: How is it trash?
其他人:这个门这都不隔热
Others: This door doesn't even insulate heat.
Jake:小米
Jake: Xiaomi.
Tasha: 这小米的
Tasha: It's Xiaomi's.
Tasha: 这不隔热
Tasha: It doesn't insulate.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe.
Tasha: 我觉得有手套还行吧
Tasha: I think it's okay if you use gloves.
其他人:他大米他也不行
Others: Even if it's rice, it still doesn't work.
Jake:这还挺香
Jake: It smells pretty good.
Jake:哎呦我去
Jake: Oh wow.
Jake:可算
Jake: Finally.
Tasha: 买可贵了
Tasha: It's really expensive.
Jake:可算拿下去了
Jake: Finally got it down.
其他人：这个这个皮感觉
Others: This, this skin feels...
其他人：然后怎么做
Others: So, how do we make it?
Tasha: 然后把洗一洗
Tasha: Then you wash it.
其他人:这能接着用吗
Others: Can we still use this?
Tasha: 不可以接着用了
Tasha: No, you can't use it again.
其他人：为什么呢
Others: Why not?
Jake:加薯片行吗
Jake: Can we add chips?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：我觉得可以
Others: I think we can.
其他人:还是就用这些还是就用这些
Others: Or just use these, just use these.
Jake:蛋挞加薯片是不是也还行啊
Jake: Adding chips to egg tarts should be okay, right?
Katrina: （歌词） 像站在烈日骄阳大桥上
Katrina: (Lyrics) Like standing on a scorching sun bridge.
Shure: 我以为你你要带什么东西
Shure: I thought you were going to bring something.
Katrina: 快
Katrina: Hurry up!
Shure: 我靠没看你引用的
Shure: Damn, I didn't see you quoting that.
Katrina: 剪刀在这吗
Katrina: Is the scissors here?
其他人：你们还要不要带打火机
Others: Do you still need a lighter?
Katrina: 我要我还没做火
Katrina: Yes, I haven't made a fire yet.
Katrina: 对不起有点拖延
Katrina: Sorry, it's been a bit delayed.
Katrina: 拖延到现在了
Katrina: Delayed until now.
Katrina: 我我出了这屋子我就成屁人回去了
Katrina: Once I leave this room, I'll be like a nobody again.
Katrina: 哎呀拆错了
Katrina: Oops, took the wrong part apart.
Katrina: 哈哈特别像那种劳改犯
Katrina: Haha, I look just like a prisoner.
Katrina: 进来改造了一下
Katrina: Came in for reformation.
Katrina: 我靠我现在只有一个隐形眼镜
Katrina: Damn, I only have one contact lens now.
Katrina: 因为另一个找不到了 600
Katrina: Because I can't find the other one. It's 600.
其他人：多少度的
Others: What's the degree?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：600能看清吗
Others: Can you see clearly with 600?
Katrina: 我一只眼睛能看清
Katrina: I can see clearly with one eye.
Katrina: 我点了外卖
Katrina: I ordered takeout.
其他人：外卖送隐形眼镜
Others: Takeout delivering contact lenses?
Katrina: 对独行侠
Katrina: Yes, a lone ranger.
Katrina: 哈哈哈配个那个海盗的那个
Katrina: Haha, like a pirate with a patch.
Shure: there once the shape broke broken sea da da da da meaning of tea
Katrina: 拆快递拆快递
Katrina: Unpack the delivery, unpack the delivery.
Katrina: YS剪刀剪刀
Katrina: YS, scissors, scissors.
Katrina: 每天都在找剪刀
Katrina: I look for scissors every day.
Tasha: 那我们就做个低糖的吧
Tasha: Then let's make a low-sugar one.
Jake:找不到吗
Jake: Can't find it?
Tasha: 不甜的甜品
Tasha: A non-sweet dessert.
其他人:是中国人对甜品的最高评价
Others: It's the highest compliment Chinese people give to dessert.
Katrina: 剪刀剪刀剪刀
Katrina: Scissors, scissors, scissors.
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake:有很多可以代替剪刀的东西
Jake: There are many things that can replace scissors.
Katrina: 这个
Katrina: This one.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Tasha: 对的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 您说什么都对
Tasha: Whatever you say is right.
Katrina: 剪刀在哪呀
Katrina: Where are the scissors?
Katrina: 抽纸盒我
Katrina: The tissue box, I...
其他人：我可以回去了
Others: Can I go back now?
其他人：我可以坐在这里度假
Others: Can I just sit here and take a vacation?
Katrina: 不需要再坐在这里比吧
Katrina: Do we really need to sit here and compete?
Alice:雨轩你有没有买一个地毯绿色的
Alice: Yuxuan, did you buy a green carpet?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Alice:我好像把你的拆错了
Alice: I think I opened the wrong one.
Katrina: 拆呗没关系啊
Katrina: It's fine, go ahead and open it.
Alice:但是我你叫什么
Alice: But I... What's your name again?
Katrina: 你帮我拆快递我不是更省事了吗
Katrina: You helped me open my package, it’s more convenient for me.
Alice:就是你是小叉吗
Alice: Are you Xiaosha?
Katrina: 小叉
Katrina: Xiaosha.
Alice:啊就是你的
Alice: Ah, so it's yours.
Alice:呃收件名
Alice: Uh, the recipient name.
Alice:那我是
Alice: Then I am...
Jake:杨鑫鑫是吧
Jake: Yang Xinxin, right?
Shure: 杨星星杨星星古丽杨星星
Shure: Yang Xingxing, Yang Xingxing, Guli Yang Xingxing.
Katrina: 买了很多
Katrina: Bought a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 天空
Shure: The sky.
Lucia:我靠我要爆粗口了
Lucia: Damn, I'm about to swear.
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What happened?
Alice:我把那个地毯给你
Alice: I’ll give you that carpet.
Alice:我说怎么感觉好像跟我印象不太一样
Alice: I was wondering why it looked different from what I remembered.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia:他那几个肯定没取上
Lucia: He definitely didn’t pick those up.
Lucia:然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted...
Lucia:跟我说申通这他取了
Lucia: Saying he picked them up from Shentong.
Lucia:问题这也没有啊
Lucia: But they're not here.
Lucia:然后那几个他也没取上
Lucia: And those others, he didn’t pick up either.
Lucia:然后他非
Lucia: And then he insisted...
Katrina: 快递全了对
Katrina: The packages are all here, right?
Lucia:说是然后他非说是驿站弄错了
Lucia: Saying it was the station's mistake.
Katrina: 公费买了很多娃娃
Katrina: He bought a lot of dolls with public funds.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 爽了爽了
Katrina: This is awesome.
Alice:啊你
Alice: Ah, you...
Alice:这个是你买的吧
Alice: This is the one you bought, right?
Katrina: 对对对哎
Katrina: Yes, yes, hey.
Katrina: 还挺好看的
Katrina: It looks pretty good.
Alice:不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Katrina: 不好意思没事
Katrina: Sorry, it's okay.
Katrina: 所以我不拍吗
Katrina: So, should I not film?
Tasha: 然后加那个
Tasha: Then add that.
Tasha: 这是哪家店
Tasha: Which shop is this?
其他人:加炼乳
Others: Add condensed milk.
Katrina: 做什么蛋挞吗
Katrina: Are we making egg tarts?
Tasha: 哎旺仔牛奶呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the Wangzai milk?
Tasha: 哦这呢
Tasha: Oh, here it is.
Tasha: 旺仔牛奶
Tasha: Wangzai milk.
其他人：加旺仔牛奶
Others: Add Wangzai milk.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
其他人：加多少
Others: How much should we add?
Tasha: 加多少克
Tasha: How many grams?
Tasha: 旁边有写
Tasha: It's written beside.
Tasha: 群芳中三阶
Tasha: It says to add 300 grams.
其他人：就是就是
Others: Exactly, exactly.
其他人：你是当纯牛奶用的
Others: You're using it like pure milk.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina: 看看他的配方
Katrina: Look at his recipe.
其他人：你当纯牛奶用
Others: You're using it like pure milk.
其他人：但我觉得糖得少加很多
Others: But I think we should add much less sugar.
其他人：115克
Others: 115 grams.
Tasha: 多少号呀多少号多少号多少号 35472
Tasha: What's the number, what's the number, what's the number 35472?
其他人：3542747235472
Others: 3542747235472.
Tasha: 手机要关机了完了
Tasha: The phone's about to die, oh no.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 不用了就这样吧
Tasha: Never mind, let's leave it like this.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Shure: 被摄像头全录下来了
Shure: The camera recorded everything.
Shure: 还没事那上半身看看
Shure: It's fine, look at the upper body.
Jake:也就8个摄像头
Jake: There are only 8 cameras.
Shure: 怕什么哈哈哈
Shure: What are you afraid of, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 给你360度还原
Shure: We'll give you a 360-degree replay.
Shure: 你的骨架
Shure: Of your skeleton.
Jake:我不敢动它不敢动它
Jake: I'm afraid to touch it, afraid to touch it.
Jake:它咬我
Jake: It might bite me.
其他人:不敢想象在这烧狗晚上得多爽
Others: Can't imagine how great it'd be to grill a dog here at night. 社会问题
其他人:哎我靠
Others: Oh, damn.
Shure: 我们烤过的
Shure: We've grilled one before.
Jake:烤了烤了3个小时
Jake: We grilled for 3 hours.
Jake:没没着火
Jake: No, no fire.
其他人：所以不是后悔了
Others: So, no regrets then.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：不敢想象在这烧烤得有多爽
Others: I can't imagine how awesome it is to barbecue here.
Alice:在这烧烤
Alice: Barbecue here.
Alice:手都快抡冒烟了
Alice: My hands are almost smoking.
Lucia:不是那为啥还是欢迎欢迎
Lucia: But why is it still "welcome, welcome"?
Lucia:我抵京啊
Lucia: I arrived in Beijing.
Jake:因为这是最后一个
Jake: Because this is the last one.
Jake:我再给你们这群加上
Jake: I'll add another one for you guys.
Lucia:太奇怪了
Lucia: So weird.
Lucia:能把它关掉吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can you turn it off? Hahaha.
Katrina: 呵
Katrina: Huh.
Jake:哈哈哈我再加几个
Jake: Hahaha, I'll add a few more.
Jake:好吧让大家一起尴尬
Jake: Alright, let everyone feel awkward together.
Lucia:对对对大家全都加上去
Lucia: Yes, yes, add everyone in.
Jake:好好好好欢迎欢迎
Jake: Okay, okay, welcome, welcome.
Jake:羞弱抵金是吧
Jake: Shure arrived in Beijing, right?
Lucia:欢迎各位抵京
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:这怎么关啊
Lucia: How do you turn this off?
Jake:欢迎修硕抵京
Lucia:太奇怪了
Lucia: So weird.
Jake:抵通可以可以
Jake: Arrived safely, alright.
Lucia:快关一下
Lucia: Turn it off quickly.
Lucia:杨老师快关一下
Lucia: Jake, turn it off quickly.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure: 人人家以为我抵制他抵制
Shure: Everyone thinks I'm boycotting, boycotting.
Jake:抵制
Jake: Boycotting.
其他人:坏了艾斯克尔又又过不了
Others: Oh no, Escher can't pass again.
Jake:抵制什么呀
Jake: Boycotting what?
Jake:你要抵制什么呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you boycotting? Hahaha.
Shure: 要再说了
Shure: Gotta say it again.
Shure: 抵制通货膨胀的
Shure: Boycotting inflation.
其他人:再说我又要打打打款机了
Others: Say it again and I'll hit the payment machine again.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Shure: 通货膨胀可以抵制一下吧
Shure: Inflation can be boycotted, right?
Jake:加两个加两个
Jake: Add two, add two.
Jake:先加一个修硕
Jake: First, add Shure.
Jake:就用你的这个
Jake: Just use yours
Jake:你你你PPT里面那照片怎么样
Jake: How about the pictures in your PPT?
Shure: 什么好
Shure: What's good?
Jake:你PPT
Jake: Your PPT
其他人:打码的打码
Others: Blur it out, blur it out
Jake:打码的
Jake: Blur it out
Shure: 你别打码的了
Shure: Don't blur it out
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 证件照吧
Shure: Let's use the ID photo
Shure: 他们朝我扔泥巴
Shure: They threw mud at me
Katrina: 我的那个
Katrina: Mine
Katrina: 我的delicate
Katrina: My delicate
Katrina: 我还买了一只Jelly cat
Katrina: I also bought a Jelly Cat
Alice:可没送到
Alice: But it didn't get delivered
Katrina: 没有我让它取了早上的
Katrina: No, I asked them to pick it up in the morning
Lucia:他有可能也拉下了
Lucia: Maybe he forgot it
Lucia:他把我好多快递都拉下了
Lucia: He forgot a lot of my packages too
Katrina: no
Katrina: No
Lucia:然后他还非说他取了啊
Lucia: And he insists he picked them up
Katrina: 我靠竟然是两个
Katrina: Wow, there are actually two
Lucia:哪个哪个女生
Lucia: Which girl?
Jake:他他不知道
Jake: He doesn't know
Jake:群里不知道是什么人
Jake: No one in the group knows who it is
Lucia:对群里不知道是
Lucia: Right, no one in the group knows
其他人:我靠这是什么
Others: Wow, what is this?
Katrina: 这是门把手的那个
Katrina: It's the door handle thing
其他人:我靠这么帅
Others: Wow, so cool
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia:有一个申通他百分百没取
Lucia: There's a Shentong package he definitely didn't pick up
Katrina: 这么便宜
Katrina: So cheap
Katrina: 竟然是两个吗
Katrina: There are actually two?
其他人：好高级呀
Others: So fancy
其他人：我靠这么可爱
Others: Wow, so cute
Jake:走我们去取
Jake: Let's go pick it up
其他人:走走let's go
Others: Let's go, let's go
Katrina: 给你一个吧
Katrina: I'll give you one
Katrina: 看看嗯
Katrina: Look, hmm
Katrina: 咱俩那个门把手
Katrina: Our door handles
其他人:let's go
Others: Let's go
Katrina: 我是我是我是
Katrina: I'm, I'm, I'm
Lucia:那也可以先去取然后行
Lucia: We can get it first, then it's fine.
Jake:我问一下
Jake: Let me ask.
Katrina: 这样那我是左手
Katrina: So, I'm using my left hand.
Katrina: 他应该是一个左手一个右手
Katrina: He should use one left hand and one right hand.
Lucia:我的胶他没给我取
Lucia: He didn't get my glue.
Katrina: 那放我家去吧
Katrina: Then just leave it at my place.
其他人：但但怎么现在才到啊
Others: But why is it just arriving now?
Katrina: 这是我们最后一天
Katrina: This is our last day.
Katrina: 装饰的对纯装饰
Katrina: It's all for decoration, purely decoration.
Alice:哎我先试试这个能贴不能吧
Alice: Let me try this first to see if it sticks.
Jake:嗯有跑腿是吧
Jake: Yeah, someone's running errands, right?
Katrina: 我的杰里卡特呢
Katrina: Where's my Jericard?
Katrina: 最贵的
Katrina: The most expensive one.
其他人：还买个杰里卡特啊
Others: You bought a Jericard too?
Jake:那我们去取快递
Jake: Then let's go pick up the package.
其他人：你是会赏识的啊
Others: You really appreciate it, huh?
其他人：你是会装饰的
Others: You really know how to decorate.
Katrina: 哈哈什么杰利卡特
Katrina: Haha, what's a Jericard?
Katrina: 我买了只小狐狸
Katrina: I bought a little fox.
Katrina: 还给他配了一条围巾
Katrina: And got it a scarf.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
其他人:我靠我一会要看看
Others: Wow, I want to see it later.
其他人:如果好如果好看的话我也要买一个
Others: If it's nice, I want to buy one too.
Jake:走走走取快递去
Jake: Come on, let's go get the package.
其他人:一一定一定
Others: Definitely, definitely.
其他人:一会要让我看那个小狐狸
Others: Show me the little fox later.
Katrina: 我找找真的没看见哎
Katrina: Let me look, I really can't find it.
其他人:一定要让我看看
Others: You must show me.
其他人:如果好看的话我买的快递都在这吗
Others: If it's nice, are all the packages here?
Lucia:如果好看我买了个小鸟
Lucia: If it's nice, I bought a little bird.
Katrina: 所有快递
Katrina: All the packages?
Katrina: 都在这吗
Katrina: Are they all here?
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
其他人:啊不肯定不全
Others: Ah, definitely not all of them.
其他人:应该不全
Others: Probably not all.
Jake:就是还没取呗
Jake: So, they haven't been picked up yet.
Lucia:不全肯百分百不全
Lucia: Definitely not all, 100% not all.
Jake:百分百不全
Jake: 100% not all.
其他人:你的手机上能看到哪些快递群
Others: Can you see which packages are in the group chat on your phone?
Lucia:全哎
Lucia: All of them.
Lucia:这好可爱
Lucia: This is so cute.
Katrina: 哦对
Katrina: Oh yeah.
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try.
其他人:像是我女朋友喜欢的东西这
Others: This looks like something my girlfriend would like.
Jake:这摩的呵呵呵还挺可爱的这摩的
Jake: This scooter, haha, it's quite cute, this scooter.
Lucia:这是干啥用的呀
Lucia: What is this for?
Katrina: 门把手上还挺可爱的
Katrina: The door handle is pretty cute too.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia:可爱真的很可爱
Lucia: Cute, it's really cute.
Katrina: 哦没取的就没签收
Katrina: Oh, if it's not picked up, it's not signed for.
Jake:对摩的然后这个
Jake: Yeah, and then this...
Katrina: 哇一个两个能打
Katrina: Wow, one or two can fight.
Jake:就
Jake: Just...
Jake:新加坡夜里面就有那个很大声音的
Jake: In Singapore at night, there's that loud noise.
其他人：先让我看到狐狸吗
Others: Let me see the fox first?
Jake:那个摩的
Jake: That scooter.
Jake:对切了之后
Jake: Yeah, and after it's cut...
Lucia:我也要看
Lucia: I want to see too.
Katrina: 哦我靠然后我给他配了一个
Katrina: Oh my gosh, and then I paired it with a scarf.
Katrina: 我给他配了一个围巾
Katrina: I paired it with a scarf.
Katrina: 我靠这真的能让老板看吗
Katrina: Oh my gosh, can the boss really see this?
Katrina: 像这样没事这个还配的围巾
Katrina: Like this, it's fine, it comes with a scarf.
Lucia:这反正老板早晚要知道的
Lucia: The boss will find out sooner or later anyway.
Jake:啥呀这个这是围巾啊
Jake: What is this? This is a scarf?
Jake:这是围巾啊
Jake: This is a scarf?
Lucia:这围巾可爱
Lucia: This scarf is cute.
Katrina: 没有没有这只是围巾的价格哈哈
Katrina: No, no, this is just the price of the scarf, haha.
其他人:哈哈哈狐狸的价格你就别看了
Others: Hahaha, don't look at the price of the fox.
其他人：狐狸的价格
Others: The price of the fox.
其他人：反正也不是你出价
Others: Anyway, it's not you paying.
其他人:反正也不是你出钱
Jake:哈哈哈我看看我看看
Jake: Hahaha, let me see, let me see.
Katrina: 预算拉满其他多的我自己提
Katrina: Budget maxed out, I’ll cover the rest.
Shure: 不是是老板出钱
Shure: No, it's the boss paying.
其他人：200块钱吧
Others: 200 bucks?
其他人:那个狐狸我感觉得200200加一个围巾
Others: That fox feels like 200, 200 plus a scarf.
Katrina: 200加一个围巾
Katrina: 200 plus a scarf.
Jake:我看看围巾是啥
Jake: Let me see what the scarf is.
Katrina: 我看看围巾是啥
Katrina: Let me see what the scarf is.
Katrina: 围巾是绿色毛茸茸手工做的
Katrina: The scarf is green, fluffy, and handmade.
其他人:一会先买家秀一下
Others: Let's do a buyer's show first.
其他人:如果好我也买一个
Others: If it's good, I'll buy one too.
其他人:卧槽这个这个
Others: Whoa, this one, this one.
其他人:明天就是一个进货的阶段
Others: Tomorrow is the stocking up phase.
Jake:对对明天
Jake: Yes, yes, tomorrow.
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina: 对没到呢
Katrina: Yeah, it hasn't arrived yet.
Katrina: 他在那个菜鸟驿站
Katrina: It's at the Cainiao station.
Jake:明天每人带个眼镜
Jake: Tomorrow, everyone bring glasses.
Jake:然后你们就对
Jake: And then you all... yeah.
Katrina: 给他建模
Katrina: Model it for him.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 走吧要去拿吗
Katrina: Let's go, should we go get it?
Jake:去拿去拿
Jake: Go get it, go get it.
Jake:走走咱俩咋去
Jake: Let's go, how do we get there?
Katrina: 今天开的没取这不行
Katrina: We didn't pick it up today, that's not good.
Jake:走去
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:那怎么办
Jake: So what do we do?
其他人：有共享单车吗
Others: Are there any shared bikes?
Jake:打车
Jake: Take a taxi.
Lucia:我看一眼那个京东应该是我的吧
Lucia: Let me check, that JD order should be mine, right?
Jake:开车开开车方便吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive?
Jake:开车方便去吗
Jake: Is it convenient to drive there?
Jake:跟牛帅说一下
Jake: Tell Nicous.
Jake:开牛帅车过去
Jake: Drive Nicous' car there.
其他人：感觉感觉里面小路不好开吧
Others: It feels like the small roads are hard to drive on.
Jake:咱没有走
Jake: We don't have to.
Jake:走大路走大路前点无法自拔
Jake: Take the main road, take the main road.
其他人:沉迷甜点无法自拔
Others: Addicted to desserts and can't pull away.
Katrina: 有点刮蹭了
Katrina: There's a bit of a scratch.
Katrina: 有点赔不起
Katrina: It's a bit unaffordable.
Shure: 虽然是个老的
Shure: Even though it's old.
Shure: 但是也是奔驰e呢
Shure: It's still a Benz E-Class.
Katrina: 天呐我们这几天有100多个快递吧
Katrina: Oh my, we have over 100 packages these days.
Katrina: 啊感觉有每个人十几个
Katrina: Yeah, feels like everyone has more than ten.
Lucia:啊哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 麦当劳不是叫过跑腿了吗
Tasha: Didn't we order McDonald's delivery?
Katrina: 我有十几个我
Katrina: I have more than ten myself.
Jake:我有20多个
Jake: I have more than twenty.
Katrina: 你也有20多个
Katrina: You have more than twenty too.
Jake:没有我我这些东西很多的
Jake: Without me, I have a lot of these things.
Tasha: 取麦当劳吗
Tasha: Are you picking up McDonald's?
Shure: 你看我给你最省
Shure: Look, I'm saving you the most.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 麦当劳不是送到门口吗
其他人：你选的多少钱
Others: How much did you choose?
Tasha: 我选择这里
Tasha: I chose here.
其他人:那我们直接走推荐
Others: Then we'll just go with the recommendation.
Tasha: 走去哪里
Tasha: Where are we going?
Jake:驿站这谁
Jake: Who's at the station?
其他人:麦当劳就一公里还开车去麦
Others: McDonald's is just a kilometer away, and you drive to get it?
Tasha: 麦当劳送到门口了
Tasha: McDonald's is delivered to the door.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:咱是取快递
Jake: We're picking up a package.
Jake:咱是要取快递
Jake:走吧
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:确实这
Jake: Indeed this...
其他人:这谁贴的
Others: Who posted this?
其他人:不知道刘帅贴的吧
Others: Don't know, was it Choiszt?
其他人:啥呀
Others: What?
其他人:不是我不一直在这呆着
Others: It wasn't me, I've been here the whole time.
Jake:不是我贴的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Katrina: 不是你吗
Katrina: Wasn't it you?
Jake:不是你吗
Jake: Wasn't it you?
其他人：真不是我
Others: It really wasn't me.
Katrina: 调监控
Katrina: Check the surveillance.
其他人：我操这个鸡蛋羹我爸一定要查出来
Others: Damn, my dad must find out about this egg custard.
Tasha: 鸡蛋羹不得搁
Tasha: Egg custard shouldn't be...
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 搁鸡蛋进去
Tasha: Put the egg in.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:挖掘三尺
Jake: Dig three feet deep.
Jake:你想想你想想
Jake: Think about it, think about it.
Lucia:早知道早知道
Lucia: If I had known...
Lucia:我就不告诉你了
Lucia: I wouldn't have told you.
Jake:你贴的时候有没有戴眼镜
Jake: Did you wear glasses when you posted it?
Lucia:原来你不知道
Lucia: So you didn't know?
Jake:不知道
Jake: Didn't know.
Lucia:哈哈不知道
Lucia: Haha, didn't know.
Jake:你你想想贴的时候戴没戴眼镜
Jake: Think, did you wear glasses when you posted it?
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 不如啊
Shure: Maybe not.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure: 什么切啥
Shure: What are we cutting?
Jake:走走走哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, let's go, haha.
Lucia:这个安康鱼也是你的吗
Lucia: Is this monkfish also yours?
Shure: 这是我我们老的队名
Shure: This is our old team name.
Jake:那根线是谁的呀
Jake: Whose wire is this?
Lucia:which one
Lucia: Which one?
Shure: 上面写名了应该
Shure: It should have a name written on it.
Lucia:啵啵啵啵
Lucia: Bop, bop, bop.
Katrina: 到
Katrina: Here.
Shure: 刘宇轩
Shure: Liu Yuxuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Hahaha, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 线怎么自己不接个好的呢
Shure: Why didn't you connect a good wire yourself?
Jake:S1C04吗
Jake: S1C04, right?
Jake:是吗你是C04吗
Jake: Is it you, C04?
Katrina: 我不记得我是谁谁谁
Katrina: I don't remember who, who, who I am.
Jake:是那就C04吧
Jake: If so, then it's C04.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Katrina: 我去拿个充电宝
Katrina: I'll go get a power bank.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina: （歌词）就算认了你就真的
Katrina: (lyrics) Even if you admit it, you really...
Shure: 我们每个人都扫了一个3D的模
Shure: Each of us scanned a 3D model.
Jake:走发
Jake: Let's send it.
其他人：扫了个人
Others: Scanned a person.
Jake:个人
Jake: A person.
其他人：扫了一个我当年的人
Others: Scanned someone from back in the day.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
其他人:我觉得那个还是很很好用的
Others: I think that one's still very useful.
其他人:虽然文件比较大
Others: Although the file is quite big.
其他人：高保真度的Max
Others: High-fidelity Max.
Shure: （歌词）听罢新征程号角吹响
Shure: (lyrics) Listen to the new journey's horn.
Lucia:（歌词）强军目标召唤在前方
Lucia: (lyrics) The goal of strengthening the army calls ahead.
Shure: （歌词）将军目标召唤在前方
其他人：还有小车
Others: There's also a small cart.
Jake:没有小车哎
Jake: There's no small cart.
Jake:问问可能
Jake: Ask, maybe...
Jake:不是我们这个院子的
Jake: It's not from our yard.
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake: Not from our yard.
Lucia:咱这人有点多哈哈
Lucia: We've got quite a few people here, haha.
Jake:不是我们这院子的
Jake: Not from our yard.
Jake:试试试试问问
Jake: Try it, try it, ask them.
Jake:别走留步
Jake: Don't go, stay here.
Jake:您您是佑佑的院子吗
Jake: Are you from Yoyo's yard?
Jake:我们想取快递啊
Jake: We want to pick up a package.
其他人：送不了好
Others: Can't deliver well.
Katrina: 我没说完呢
Katrina: I haven't finished yet.
Katrina: 就是嗯
Katrina: So, um...
Katrina: 我们每个人都有十几个快递
Katrina: Each of us has over a dozen packages.
Katrina: 感觉这几天有100多个快递吧
Katrina: It feels like there are over 100 packages these days.
Katrina: 然后他有那个管家就没有取全
Katrina: And the manager didn't pick them all up.
Katrina: 然后我要自己去取
Katrina: So I have to pick them up myself.
Katrina: 因为我的jellycat它没给我取到
Katrina: Because my Jellycat wasn't picked up.
Katrina: 这是我的贵重物品
Katrina: It's my valuable item.
其他人：用个f可还行
Others: Using an F is okay.
Lucia:哈哈哈啊一颗星
Lucia: Hahaha, one star.
其他人：那那一会
Others: Then later...
其他人：那一会你头上就是一颗星
Others: Then later you'll have a star on your head.
Jake:哈哈偷我车是不会的吧
Jake: Hahaha, stealing my car wouldn't happen, right?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 一般偷个车不会的吧
Shure: Normally, stealing a car wouldn't happen, right?
其他人:偷车在在洛洛洛圣都是不会机智
Others: Stealing a car in Los Santos is not a good idea.
其他人:但在别的地方就不一定
Others: But in other places, it might be different.
Lucia:什么GTA
Lucia: What, GTA?
其他人:感觉路上路
Others: Feels like on the road...
Lucia:路上哈哈哈
Lucia: On the road, haha.
其他人:我们如果只偷个车的话
Others: If we only steal a car...
其他人:出一嗨再往从天上掉个坦克
Others: Then later a tank will drop from the sky.
其他人:哈哈哈我记得有那个
Others: Hahaha, I remember that.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人:有一个什么暗语
Others: There was some code.
其他人:就是什么输一输一个英文单词
Others: You input some English word.
其他人:然后跟什么无伤跑的巨帅
Others: And then you can run invincibly.
其他人:子弹无限
Others: Infinite bullets.
Jake:对哎
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure: 秘籍可多了
Shure: There are a lot of cheats.
Jake:咱有导航吗
Jake: Do we have navigation?
Shure: 咱没导航
Shure: We don't have navigation.
Jake:哈哈哈傻子
Jake: Hahaha, idiot.
Shure: 咱在这瞎瞎鸡走什么呢哈
Shure: What are we messing around here for?
Katrina: 笑自己消音是吧
Katrina: Laughing at yourself, huh?
Jake:这真打GT啊
Jake: Is this really GT?
Jake:难走哈哈哈
Jake: Hard to walk, hahaha.
Lucia:咱那群我怎么找不着啊
Lucia: How come I can't find our group?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Lucia:找着了
Lucia: Found it.
其他人：哇飞机
Others: Wow, a plane.
Shure: 当然当然
Shure: Of course, of course.
Shure: 别瞎看啊
Shure: Don't just look around.
Shure: 你没戴眼镜没事
Shure: It's fine if you don't have glasses.
Lucia:先去菜鸟吗
Lucia: Shall we go to Cainiao first?
其他人:我看飞机应该没什么吧
Others: I think it's fine to look at the plane.
Jake:你看飞机没什么
Jake: It's fine to look at the plane.
Lucia:菜鸟的话
Lucia: As for Cainiao...
Shure: 对我们看不行
Shure: Yeah, we can't look.
Katrina: 我们不能看
Katrina: We can't look.
其他人:为什么谁知道的
Others: Why? Who knows?
Katrina: 万一是战斗机呢
Katrina: What if it's a fighter jet?
Shure: 谁知道这眼镜戴不戴透视
Shure: Who knows if these glasses see through?
Jake:透视哈
Jake: See-through, huh?
Shure: 哈哈哈麦塔告诉我们是没戴那
Shure: Hahaha, Metta told us we didn't have them.
Lucia:如果说是那个菜鸟的话
Lucia: If it's Cainiao...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁知道杨老板知道多些呢
Shure: Who knows, maybe Jake knows more.
Lucia:好像是这个方向
Lucia: Seems like this direction.
Lucia:然后这样然后这样然后这样然后这样
Lucia: Then like this, then like this, then like this.
Jake:那咱可不知道
Jake: We really don't know.
Jake:啥也不知道
Jake: We don't know anything.
Lucia:真不知道
Lucia: Really don't know.
Shure: 真不知道
Shure: Really don't know.
其他人:好非常的形象
Others: Very vivid.
Lucia:哈哈对吧
Lucia: Haha, right?
其他人:对非常形象
Others: Yes, very vivid.
Lucia:对特别详细
Lucia: Yes, very detailed.
Katrina: 这这哦这就是菜鸟一只
Katrina: This, oh, this is just a Cainiao.
Lucia:对它里面好像只发个菜鸟
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like it only sends a Cainiao.
Lucia:和一个别的什么
Lucia: And something else.
Katrina: 今天得把这个取回来
Katrina: We have to get this back today.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:味太对了
Others: The flavor is just right
Jake:走走走要撞墙
Jake: Go, go, go, you'll hit the wall
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人:要有要一个人过来给你
Others: Someone needs to come over and help you
Jake:哈哈哈嚯
Jake: Hahaha